roroute.
L L'arsenic n'est pas juste das
l'l'air extérieur à Rouyn-Noran.
OnOn en a trouvé dans des maisos
etet dans une garderie!
RaRadio-Canada a prélevé et
ananalysé des échantillons
dede poussière intntérieure.
S Sébastien Sauvé, professeur
enen chimie de l'environnement
àà l'Université de Montréal,
a a accompagné notre collègue
ThThomas Gerbet dans cette
dédémarche. Il est avec nous
cece matin.
B Bonjour M. Sauvé.
- - Bonjour.
- - Un taux d'arsenic supérieur
àà la norme acceptable dans
plplusieurs endroits de la mais.
VoVous vous attendiez à ça?
- - Oui, j'étais convaincu qu'on
veverrait des traces d'arsenic.
LeLes méthodes d'analyse sont ts
sesensibles et donc on va être
cacapable de détecter de laisse
ararsenic. Et comme les seuls
élélans sont contaminés, c'est
évévident qu'il allait y avoir
dadans les maisons. La question
c'c'est combien on va mesurer et
esest-ce qu'on va dépasser le
seseuil acceptable, est-ce qu'on
esest dans une zone à risque.
J'J'étais convaincu qu'il est en
ararrêt.
- - Mais c'est presque aussi
cocontaminé dans certaines maiss
quque dans le milieu industriel,
c'c'est presque la même quantité
énénorme.
- - Ce n'est pas comme dans le
mimilieu industriel mais dans
cecertains cas on dépasse les
nonormes acceptables même pour n
mimilieu industriel. Dans un
mimilieu industrie annuel calcul
unune exposition pouour les adus
ququi travailleront sur ce sitet
sosont la 8 heures par jour cinq
jojours par semaine et que de
trtravailler dans un, une usinùu
lele sol à l'extérieur sont
cocontaminé à ces niveaux peut
êêtre inquiétant pour un adulte
huhuit heures papar jour cinq js
papar semaine. Si on a la même
coconcentration dans une maisonl
y y a des enfants qui circulentt
papassent presque la totalité de
leleur temps, l'exposition est
plplus élevée et on change le
paparadigme d'exposition et c'et
plplus inquiétant.
- - Quand on regarde cela, dans
l'l'air c'est peut-être moins pe
mamais ça se démo pose sur les
obobjets dans la nourriture. Làa
vivient nous frapper tout à cou.
AuAu moins il y a des gens qui
vivivent là, des enfants. Est-ce
quque c'est acceptable qu'ils
vivivent là? Comment se fait-il
ququ'il n'y a pas de mécanisme
popour leur dire faut sortir dea
cacare vous mettait votre vie
vovotre santé en danger?
- - On ne le voit pas et donc
c'c'est dans l'imaginaire et
sasalaire moins grave. Quand on
memesure les poussières d'une
mamaison recueillie dans un
asaspirateur qui en accumulait u
enen surface des objets, on se
trtrouve avoir un regard sur la
ququalité de ce qui est petit et
flflotte d dans l'air qui finitr
sese déposer et c'est une façone
memesurer ce qui est respiré das
lala rue qu'on ne voit pas et de
vovoir cette exposition c'est
ininquiétant et il faut le
rarappeler l'arsenic c'est
cacancérigène et donc ce n'est s
esesthétique, ce n'est pas un
sosouci esthétique c'est un nome
dede cancers qui va augmenter ds
cece quartier et dans cette régn
paparce qu'ils sont exposés à ps
dede cancérigène que ce qui est
nonormalement jugé acceptable.
- - Déménageur étiez-vous dans e
ququartier Notre-Dame quand on
vovoit les données que vous avez
pupu analyser? Est-ce que c'est
réréaliste de penser qu'on peut
vivivre lente faisant le ménage
rérégulièrement c'est fou l'idé?
- - Non. J'ai beaucoup de
sysympathie pour les gens qui
hahabitent dans ce quartier. Ce
n'n'est pas simple. Clairement e
nene voudrais pas déménager là t
jeje serais inquiet si j'avais e
lala famille qui habitait dans e
ququartier. Surtout pour des
jejeunes enfants, les enfants en
gagarderie, ça ne fait pas de
sesens.
JeJe pense qu'il faut améliorer
leles conditions pour les gens
dadans le quartier. Plusieurs
ststratégies peuvent être misesn
chcharge, en place, le nettoyage
dedes sols et peut-être des règs
plplus strictes et plus rapidemt
avavant de voir l'amélioration
ququand on parle d'un produit ds
cacancérigène. Il faut t garderà
ttête l'objectif dans cinq ans
rereste cinq fois plus élevées e
lala norme au Québec. Ça reste
ququelque chose, on est assez
gégénéreux ou assez permissif pr
lala norme reconnue, par rapporà
lala norme reconnue et c'est das
cicinq ans. Donc c'est un
prproblème.
- - C'est inquiétant. On a
bebeaucoup de sympathie pour cex
ququi vivent la n'ont peut-être
papas les moyens de déménager à